okay I have two activities that I've
prepared so interpretation this idea of
constructing meanings or developing
meanings about works of art or we can
think of interpretation as you know
someone is speaking one language and
then we take that language and we are
able to not only do we speak and
understand this language but then we can
translate a closed ideas in those words
and turn them into a different language
that someone else speak so we can have
interpretation function in that way as
well so it's about taking ideas from one
context into into another or one mode of
representation and communication into
another but in terms of art and art
practice art criticism and
interpretation work work together so
this image I think is useful for our
purposes here imagine that this image
was the poster for a movie right
full-length feature length movie and
imagine you were responsible for for
writing the copy for writing the text
for the voice-over of the movie trailer
but all you had was this image to go by
you probably heard movie trailers you
know there's little commercials for
movies and usually in my experience they
start off with one of two phrases or a
version of one of two phrases one of the
phrases is usually something like this
imagine a place right and you can
imagine you've heard this phrase before
it for movie trailers imagine a place
and the music could start to engine
tuned you see the scenery
another phrase that is often used is in
a world where right you see group I see
nodding going on so that means all right
you probably name several films that
have movie trailers that start that way
so take one of those phrases
imagine a place or in a world and know
if you have I don't if you have
something to write with or if you want
to keep it in your head and if you come
up with a sentence or two that would be
great but the sentence or two that
starts with one of those two prompts
would function as the beginning
voiceover copy for the movie from which
this still comes we got it alright
here's the movie trailer
so part of what I'm hearing it like I
heard swimming upstream adversity these
water hoses I heard it was issue of
control resistance this border walls
suggest there's something about being in
and out and not being able to attain
something and then the x-games the the
what you call the what cheerleading
extreme ultimate cheerleading extreme
cheerleading so there's an activity but
then there's something else that pushes
it or ramps it up add some context here
this is an a still image from a
performance by performance artist Dred
Scott the title of the work is called on
the impossibility of freedom in a
country founded on slavery and genocide
and he's referencing a range of events
but specifically a particular event in
the 60s where there was a protest
against racial injustice where the
authorities used water hoses
high-powered water hoses to push back
African Americans this was not a single
event this is these kinds of things
happen all the time in the 60s so this
is part of dred Scott's performance this
is still from his performance I find it
remarkable listening to even the comedy
trailer that you were picking up on
elements of what his performance what he
intended his performance to be
but also what other people have
interpreted his performance to be about
Charles go Ryan is a performance artist
and art educator who also taught high
school in the Bay Area in San Francisco
and he taught his students in late 60s
in the 70s into the 80s actually I
believe about performance art and
happenings and the ways in which our
bodies can perform symbolically to
construct works of art that relate to
social issues and cultural issues so his
work is documented in several of his
books one of which is called performing
pedagogy where he interprets several
works of art and performance art and
then provides a set of activities that
teachers and their students can perform
to learn some of the basic structures or
some elements of performance art using
one's body as part as an artistic medium
but also a way in which to comment on
social issues but it's the idea of using
our bodies as symbolic vehicles that
become powerful and also the ways that
our bodies can move in a the ways in
which our bodies interact with other
objects or other ideas the way in which
we might maybe think of taking our body
doing something to it doing something
else to it so there's an activity that I
often do with my students undergrads
graduate students students who are
learning to be teachers that I borrowed
from Charles gray and here's a still
image of one student doing this and what
I'd like you to do is to identify a
statement could be an excerpt
it could be song lyrics it could be a
poem but it needs to be a set of words
that ideally it's a text that or a
sentence or several phrases that you
could or someone else could say within a
30-second time period so borrow from
Charles grands approach one of the
activities is to take an image and a
body and the body engages in a
repetitive motion a repetitive activity
and the idea is that that body in motion
in relationship to were in juxtaposition
with or in critique or conversation with
that image will inherently start to
construct or
suggest different interpretations just
like what you did we saw the image and
you added some text to that but there's
a third element and that's the text that
you've come up with so what is going to
happen so here's another student doing
something similar so what's going to
happen is I'm going to hit this button
and then I'm gonna go over here and I'm
gonna start performing I want to do a
repetitive motion for 30 seconds when I
get over there you're gonna speak your
text yes no no oh you would rather not
share your text that would be fine all
right we'll do that and then I have two
other images so we'll be able to get to
other people but you'll see how this
works ready go okay
sometimes you gotta post bad pictures of
yourself online so that people are
impressed with it when they see you in
person sometimes you got to post bad
pictures of yourself online so that
people aren't impressed when they see
you in person sometimes you got to post
bad pictures of yourself online so that
people are impressed when they see you
in person
sometimes you gotta post bad pictures of
yourself online so that people are
impressed when they see whether person
I'm alright thank you very trust him cuz
you know three minutes could have been
30 things you see what happened we have
a repetitive motion which might suggest
certain ideas and concepts meanings we
had this text be where it would say that
say it again Oh sometimes you have to
post that pictures of yourself online so
that people are impressed when they see
you in person so now we have that text
and we gotta put in relationship to this
movement but this image what is this
image have to do with this movement I
mean it's interesting you can put two
ideas together or put these two things
together or these two things together
but all three of them anybody want to
attempt to weave these three together go
ahead
since the theme of repetition like I
didn't catch it at first but the fact
that you kept repeating it and then your
hop kind of synced in with that and then
looking at this image just the fact that
there's all these windows and all the
pieces of the image like deconstructed
sort of fell into this
it's like cycle of posting pictures
online and seeing people multiple times
and it's right in time come together
okay right so why would I do something
like that well at the end of the
semester the students in one of my
graduate class that I teach at Penn
State and also at Vermont College of
Fine Arts after going through that
process of the randomness of making
those connections they then have to go
through the process of intentionally
combining image text and body movement
for a public performance that lasts at
least five minutes so these are the top
row is our stills from one video the
bottom row are stills from another one
and one at the top the student was
interested in the idea that someone told
her at one point something like well
there have never been any Wars
international Wars on US soil and she
thought this doesn't make any sense and
a history teacher told her that so the
idea was that this performance speaks
back to that this was performed in
Philadelphia and so you can see in these
three different images she's using her
body and different way she's holding a
photo of a satellite photo of a plane
bombing she created almost a little
memorial and burial for this and has
watered it generously and then puts her
own body down in this bench that is
essentially a whispering bench where if
she she's sitting at one end and can
whisper into the corner and the person
sitting at the other end can hear what
she's saying and one at the bottom is a
student who performed outside of court
she that's at Carnegie Hall up front of
Carnegie Hall and symbolically speaking
to a death in her family but also her
own musical aspirations and the way in
which there's they relate to her own
life but also she was equated it to to
gun violence and so she was cleaning the
clarinet and you puts it in this case in
very in various ways that make you
they suggest is this a musical
instrument or is it an implement for an
instrument of killing
so these are some outgrowths from that
quick assignment that we did so in
summary we you could engage learners
like we've done today in any of these
ways or you could do boring stuff it's
really up to you
you